actor strike is over everybody back to
work but um let's take a look at the new
contract shall
[Music]
we hey there folks yes the SAG after
strike is
over effectively like the they they have
an agreement it has been cleared by the
initial sort of uh committee that it
needs to clear within sagra the members
have to vote uh to finally ratify it
that'll happen a little bit the odds are
very likely that the vote will ratify
the agreement um not everyone loves it
but that's actually kind of the case
pretty much every time the expectation
is that it will um clear that and things
are starting to pick up again with that
in mind including me getting back to my
regular work schedule as it was before
the strike or at least working on that
that having been said this is a bit more
complicated because can I be honest uh
wrapping up this strike took longer than
I thought especially in the wake of the
writer strike wrapping up in fact at the
time the writer strike wrapped up I had
my thumbnail guy Joel mock together this
because I thought it would effectively
wrap up almost immediately after the
writers and have a similar outcome and
uh I'm not going to be using that
thumbnail not because the deal is like a
disaster or anything but just because
it's a lot more complicated it's not as
unambiguous a victory as the writer
Guild uh results were so there's a fair
amount of stuff to go over of course the
main stumbling thing for why this is not
as clear-cut a we got pretty much
everything we wanted I say we I'm not a
member of either Guild but um I support
both unions so feels like a victory for
uh folks in general but yes it's not
just a case of uh like with the writers
Gil it was they got basically everything
that they were asking for and it really
did just make the studios look like
absolute jerks for taking so long to
give in on these points with the actors
clearly there was actually more give and
take that had to happen particularly
with the realm of AI but since AI is the
most complicated we're going to table
that we're going to come back to that
further down the line but before I even
get into any other stuff cuz there's
other stuff in that contract even though
AI is sucking up all the oxygen in the
room and it's the main point of
contention
um there's other stuff to go over which
I think is interesting and pretty much
all good but uh before I get into any of
this couple of caveats because this was
technically also the case with the
Writers Guild one but again The Writers
Guild agreement was not as
um mired in um some very harsh reactions
that I've started to see to this thing
so there's a couple of things I want to
put up front the first is I'm not a
contract lawyer probably shouldn't need
to to tell you that but just making it
clear I have looked over the available
information to the best of my ability
and interpreted to the best that I'm
going to be able to do are there going
to be ways that it could go or possible
holes in what's there or whatever that I
am not able to see yeah absolutely
that's why they don't have me
negotiating this stuff but here's the
other thing I want you to keep in mind
especially before you before you start
throwing at me any arguments that you
are seeing being made especially on
Twitter right now about why this is a
bad deal what is currently publicly
available is the summary now the summary
is 18 pages long and fairly detailed but
it is not the contract it is the summary
now the reason I want to bring that
forward is because obviously the actual
agreement the full detailed granular
agreement has a lot more to it a lot
more specific wording a lot more really
nailed down stuff probably more
definitions does that mean that anything
that looks like it might be a loophole
in the summary is definitely covered in
the full version no it doesn't mean that
but it also means that when I see people
getting really up insisting well it says
this and that means and painting it in
the worst way possible I feel the need
to point out like that's the summary
you're reacting to again point out flaws
it's not a Flawless thing but let's all
take a breath and realize that what we
have access to what pretty much everyone
is reacting to is a summary so we still
presume that the summary is accurate to
the intention of the final thing
therefore I will be talking about it but
anyone who starts getting really
nitpicky about the granular details
realize they don't have the actual
details okay because I'm already see
just just on Twitter alone which granted
is a hive of scum and villainy that
where fights will break out at any
moment but even within that I've seen
things get real heated real fast but
again we're going to put AIS side cuz
there's a fair amount of other stuff to
talk about so let's go over some of that
first of all AR raise General raise
across the board the general raise is 7%
the raise for background performers is
actually higher it's 11% and then for
both there will be subsequent raises of
4% next year and then 3 and a half% the
year after that but the um whole thing
has actually pretty clearly been crafted
with a much stronger eye on the people
who just get paid scale I.E minimum wage
for actors a lot of the real detailed
specifics are covered in that there's
actually eventually when we get to the
AI even a few cases where if you are a
schedule F Union member I.E the biggest
names and the biggest stars some of the
stuff doesn't automatically apply to you
and while it doesn't say that in the
contract my assumption would be is part
of the reason for that is when you are
at the upper echelons you have have your
own contract people you have lawyers
pouring over these things whereas all
the people on the lower end can't afford
that and they need a good blanket strong
overall contract covering everybody so
there actually does seem to be a pretty
good heavy emphasis on benefiting the
people at the bottom of the totem pole
at least in terms of what they're
getting paid and how much work they're
getting as much as possible which I
think is overall a good thing and this
raise and how it's structured is kind of
indicative of that next up intimacy
coordinators are going to be required
for any scene that is a sex scene or
involves nudity this is also good this
has become a little bit of an increasing
issue in film making in general but in
Hollywood in particular because there's
a very very very long history of
performers usually um women actors but
like actors across the board being taken
advantage of put into positions where
they feel uncomfortable and just
generally being coerced into work that
they might not be comfortable with
because they are having to deal directly
with the director Andor producer who's
pushing them to do what they're not
comfortable with and an intimacy
coordinator is there to ensure that you
know everything happens as was agreed in
advance for the people going into this
scene that includes coordinating things
like who's going to be on set how the
behavior is going to be how it's going
to be shot intimacy coordinators are not
there to stop nudity and Sexes from
happening they are there to make sure
that when they do happen they happen as
secure purely and ethically as possible
this is a good thing and yes I have
heard the thing from some actors
generally of the older generation who
have um usually men uh who have had
complaints that an intimacy Coordinator
would impede their ability to perform a
scene like that like it would make it
difficult to be present in what is meant
to be conveyed as an intimate moment for
the camera when there's somebody right
there watching what you do make sure you
you do what was agreed to and don't
cross the line and while I do understand
because I've seen seen enough things
like that in some cases it really does
come across like grumpy old men who
don't want to be told what to do but it
has come from a couple of actors who it
felt more legitimate and I do understand
that it can be difficult especially if
it's not something you're used to having
there and how it could throw you off um
but my answer to that is
tough tough it is more important for
everyone who is having to be naked and
in close physical proximity to each
other and being filmed um even if the
nudity is not total or is being masked
in some way like Comfort is more
important we can edit around how good
your performance is to be frank and uh
people's Comfort is more important than
that so while I get it and I'm not going
to say that that is a completely invalid
concern uh suck it up and get over it
next up this one's interesting principal
actors will be consulted on hair and
makeup and not just kind of thrown into
a hair and makeup trailer with no saying
what's going on this might seem like a
little bit weird to have this actually
has a pretty big impact on actors who
are people of color because what's been
a bit of a recurring issue on a lot of
film sets is black hair especially is
different from White hair it behaves
differently it needs to be treated
differently it needs to be handled
differently in terms of the health of
the hair and also in terms of getting it
to do what you want it to do and not all
hairdressers know how to do both and
it's become a bit of a recurrent issue
on some um sets and filming locations
for TV and movies where performers of
color with specific needs for their hair
and makeup are being put in the hands of
a hair and makeup team that don't know
how to work with them and the results
are either uncomfortable or just poor it
just looks bad when that's not what's
supposed to happen so this is an effort
to address that and also has a caveat
where if the um shoot and the studio or
whoever has not been able to provide
this and the performer has to bring in
their own people they are going to be
reimbursed for the cost of bringing in
someone who they know knows how to deal
with their hair so again I think this is
pretty much a good thing next up we got
something that kind of crosses over uh
and actually pretty much mirrors what
went on with the wga and that is bonuses
for streaming now like the wga uh actors
and the SAG after Union are going to
start seeing the numbers for um the
actual streaming CU that was part of the
contention numbers and actual viewing
percentages Etc have not been public
they don't have to be not the way that
things on broadcast television are so
while that information will still not be
made public it should be but will still
not be made public at the very least
people who should be getting bonuses and
residuals based off some being in
something really successful will now
have access to that information and it
also sets a structure where if a show or
a film is viewed by 20% of the
subscriber base of that service 20% or
more they get a bonus on that now that
is a threshold that at least so far as
the metrics and the people who have been
monitoring this because as I said
streaming numbers don't get made public
but there are analysts who look at this
and have a general idea of how things
turn out uh something doing that well is
going to be something that is a big hit
it's not super common for something to
hit a 20% saturation or higher but it is
also not an impossible metric things
that are generally considered to be big
hits on streaming tend to hit that so
that seemed like a good balance and a
good number and I believe it is also the
same one that the wga was using to
structure its bonuses for successful
streaming shows so that is pretty much
the same deal the one other thing before
we start trying to parse all the AI
stuff has to do with audition tapes and
audition streaming zooms anything like
that basically anything where an actor
is either submitting um a video or doing
an audition remotely in some fashion
whether it be for health and safety
concerns physical limitations because
they have some kind of disability or
they're just not physically able to make
it to the audition space that is
something that has been allowed for for
a while but there were some problems
with how it was structured some of the
big ones being there would often be a
minimum like the picture quality has to
at least be x i I don't know what it was
but like some of these um places some of
these casting places or directors or
Studios or whatever would basically
expect it to look at at least this good
at to a degree that actors who if you're
going in for an open audition you're not
a name and they would have to Shell out
for higher end production stuff they'd
have to get lights and good cameras and
a good sound equipment that is just
money that they shouldn't have to spend
when all that's being judged is their
ability to perform a scene not how well
the scene can be shot in their home so
guard rails have been put in place for
that where they uh where the casting
directors and whatnot cannot cannot set
those kinds of expectations for how good
the visual quality of the video is
obviously like if it's so bad you can't
even hear them yeah they probably won't
use that but they can't be like you know
if it you send it in 4k or we don't want
it they can't do anything like that and
they kind of could before um also some
things in regards to putting up uh
guidelines for what happens to those
audition videos after the casting
process because when a casting is hosted
you know by the um either the casting
company or the studio or whatever
they're shooting it on their equipment
they own that footage but there wasn't
really clear guidelines on what happens
to audition material not shot by these
people but sent to them there are now
guidelines for what can and can't happen
with that and also they've made it a
rule where if it is a general and open
casting call you can't have a fee you
can't say oh here's a general casting
call uh but you have to pay $500 for us
to uh consider you for audition because
while the $500 number I pulled out of my
butt I just guessed a number having fees
for General auditions was something that
would happen and it's nonsense again the
union kind of looking out to the people
trying to break in or the people who
aren't established names aren't getting
regular work and just need better
opportunities and need to not be fleeced
and have the and have themselves taken
advantage of for nonsense reasons again
these are good guard rails to have but
that does mean that we have gotten to AI
so here's where things get tricky and
messy I think part of why some people
are going to this and pulling it apart
and looking for every possible way can
be taken advantage of which like broadly
speaking I support as a practice because
you know don't trust the studios that's
why you need a contract because you
can't trust them but I think the thing
is there were a lot of hardliners out
there whether they were actual members
of the union or not I think in general
there's a lot of hardliners who wanted
the knees taken out from underneath um
AI altogether they wanted a hard no AI
rule which is kind of what happened with
the wga technically AI is still allowed
in there but it's basically only if the
writer who has already been brought onto
a project agrees to work with AI and is
they still get paid the same as if they
weren't going to work with that so they
put the control into the writer's hands
and as far as like setting up a writer
room or an overall pitch or anything
like that wga just went no you don't get
to do any of that and I think some
people were hoping for something similar
with the actors contract the thing is
that was never going to happen the main
reason that wasn't going to happen was
because AI with the writers was largely
future proofing or at least an attempt
to Future proof and deal with potential
things that might happen later because
AI at least so far as we are aware
hasn't really been used in the writing
process it has hasn't frankly it hasn't
gotten good enough to be able to do that
AI in post- production regarding actors
has been in use for a little while now
it was very important to put guard rails
in and and do all this and do all this
stuff and we're going to talk about some
of the stuff that's now in the new
contract but broadly speaking AI was
already in use because whether it be um
you know just a little tweak to uh an
image using an AI uh algorithm or
assistance or you know slight altering
of the image or a lot of things like the
daging that has a lot of AI involved AI
is already a component to a fair amount
of post-production special effects work
so this wasn't just a case of we have to
stop them from getting in the door
they're already in the door so you have
to deal with the ways in which it is
already being used while trying to stop
it being abused in other ways later so
anybody who was hoping for a hard no
AI honestly I don't think that was
realistic would I have preferred that
personally well yeah kind of but I don't
think that was ever realistically going
to happen the main thing about AI was
cutting off the ability to take
advantage in ways that would that just
were horrible some of the things that it
was rumored the studios were proposing
and wanted to be able to do were awful
but AI is already a thing you can't just
get rid of it completely it's become
ingrained to in small way
in too many Productions and I'll
actually talk about some of the ways AI
has been getting used because it comes
up in an interesting way that again I've
seen interpreted in odd ways in some
places but okay let's get to this now
the AI section is long and is complex
and a lot of it is definitions
definitions of AI definitions of
specific types of AI whether it is an
independent creation or if it's
derivative derivative of an existing
performance there are actually different
terminologies for all these different
uses so a lot of what's in there is
defining terms which especially with
something like this that doesn't have um
common use parament where if you use
this term everyone understands it to
mean X thing you need to do a lot of
definitions so there's a lot of that
there and the main thing uh the term you
will see come up frequently is consent
not just that consent needs to be
acquired but it needs to be very clear
and they actually have it laid out at
pretty much nearly every type no matter
what it is if you are applying AI to an
actor's performance or using their
performance as a basis for AI consent
has to be attained whether it be at the
time of the initial work or if you're
adding it in as a new thing you need to
get consent on that there's also a lot
of structure for residuals on this so
for example if uh a digital duplicate is
created of a performer and is used um
either in a film for their whole
performance or for certain parts of a
film like if they weren't able to shoot
at this location and they use a digital
double they do have to compensate that
performer for as many days as they would
have been on set had they been there to
shoot it themselves and also this
applies to background performers so this
one's big they have to be given
residuals based off screen time exactly
the same as if they had been filmed as
opposed to have been digitally
duplicated so these were some of the
kinds of things that there were a lot of
concerns about and as I said consent is
a big one and it's there a lot and it's
there pretty much following every
definition that goes down the list now
there is one section and this is one of
the things that I think a lot of
people they saw the heading and they
kind of freaked and I get why but this
is kind of what I mean uh when I say
some people seem to have just come in
with the harshest possible read and like
have just assumed everything AI related
since it didn't say no AI must be a
problem and that in that there is a
section for exceptions to consent now as
a phrase that sounds bad if there's all
these things in place like well you
can't duplicate me without consent and
you can't do this without consent you
can't alter my performance without
consent you can't do these things but
then there's a section for exceptions to
consent that seems that's that seems
bad but if you look at it this is
basically codifying the Stu that's
already kind of standard and that I
think at least is pretty harmless so
some of the specific things include
minor alterations to say costuming say
uh a performer's costume looks wrong
they get into the editing suite and it
was lit in such a way that it does not
look like the color that it was supposed
to and they decide to use AI to alter
that color rather than having to go in
and do it manually that would be allowed
without consent if they used AI to get
like a loose strand of hair out of
somebody's face that could be done
without consent if they used AI to fix a
little bit of lip sync if they'd had to
dub over um a performance after effect
because maybe there was too much onset
sound but now the uh audio track they
have doesn't fully match up with the
with the lip movements and they use AI
to better syn the lips to the sound that
would be permissible without consent so
these kinds of tiny post- production
tweaks that are already the most common
use of AI in post-production those are
allowed without consent now again coming
back to what I said way at the start the
definitions of this of these things
matter and their clarifications for the
extent that it is allowed to happen
without consent is also very important
but again what I have is a summary not
the full thing and based off the summary
and at least the spirit of this I
understand why these exceptions to
consent are there because these are the
kind of tiny tweaks that have already
become kind of standard in the
production Pipeline and if they have to
Halt uh post production for every little
correction of this nature in order to
attain permission again from an actor
and to get consent to adjust tiny things
like fixing a stray hair removing blinks
if somebody is meant to be playing like
an Android or something or fix or color
correcting or removing like a single
wrinkle off a face that they decide they
don't want there or what have
you that that would become frankly a
bureaucratic mess if they had to stop
and get permission for every single
instance like that every single time now
again the specifics of this do matter
the specifics that I don't have and
neither does anybody else who is not
actually in the Union at least so far as
I know all I've seen that's been put out
is the summary and generally that's the
way it goes um but I think that the idea
of these
exceptions makes sense is it abusable
depends on the specific wording but at
least in concept I don't think this is
the end of the world there's also one
other area where I've seen people get
nervous and this has to do with a
section under independently created
digital replicas basically these aren't
necessarily being based off of scans or
off of a performance they're being
created independent of a normal piece of
contracted work that an actor would be
involved in and under that there are
some more exceptions which basically
tries to account for fair use so that
any situation where it would normally be
acceptable to use clips of an actor be
it from a movie be it from an interview
be it uh images Etc if it would be
acceptable to use them under standard
fair use rules it would also be
acceptable to make use of an
independently created digital replica of
that performer this is probably the one
that has the most potential for abuse
depending on how everything is very
specifically laid out in the full
contract in the summary some examples
that it gives would be comment criticism
scholarship satire or parody use in docu
drama or historical or biographical work
again kind of defaulting to what would
standardly fall under fair use but in
the summary at least there's no language
indicating that a digital replica can't
be used to say something that the person
never said or like there's no evidence
they ever said that but you make them
say it anyway just to make it seem
authentic that is the kind of thing that
could be a concern cuz even if you mark
it under parody well as we've seen on
Twitter when the blue check mark went up
for sale even if something appears like
it should be parody If at first glance
it looks authentic it can cause big
problems so while I understand the
concerns about stepping on First
Amendment and fair use rights in regards
to these specific exceptions I would say
that depending on how things are defined
in the F contract this is the one area
where there's some holes here but it is
worth noting that as far as major
studios are concerned they're really not
going to be able to take advantage of
this because none of what they are doing
that they normally hire these actors for
fall under these exceptions but it does
still leave open the possibility of
basically malicious Mischief another
thing that's in there like as a phrase
that I think freaked a lot of people out
was the idea that death does not
discharge consent and I think that gave
people flashbacks to the stories we'd
had before of Studios wanting to be able
to scan an actor once and then use that
scan and that data in perpetuity in
anything for forever even after the
person dead and they just get to own
that and that was a very scary Prospect
but the thing about the consent not
being discharged upon death unless
otherwise specified in a contract
is kind of a standard thing basically
what that means is you already gave your
informed and and again the specifics are
probably going to be in the full
contract but these things don't just say
consent and like a oh you can sneak it
in they're like you have people have to
be clear they have to know and there's
rules for arbitration if someone is
going to dispute that consent was um not
properly informed and all that's aside
that all that's in there as well but if
you have given your consent that your
digital duplicate can be utilized in
this
film after you die they are still
allowed to use it in that film it
doesn't grant them new ability to do
with your digital duplicate anything
they couldn't do before what it does is
it makes clear that when you're dead
your existing consent for the ways in
which it was used still remain because
otherwise it opens up the possibility of
uh the people who end up running the
estate of a deceased actor or possibly
their next ofkin or whoever might be
around that has a legal claim could make
demands to renegotiate reup or get a new
payment to basically sign off again now
that they're dead this again kind of
thing is fairly standard a lot of
contracts are designed to still be valid
even after somebody dies some are
designed to be void upon somebody's
death and it can vary it isn't
necessarily automatically one or the
other but that's why there's clarifying
language in this now in theory if
somebody did get kind of conned into
signing uh away more rights than they
realized they were and there's this uh
it doesn't just charge with death thing
is that a little scary well do yeah a
little bit but you you kind of jumped
over a problem that needs to be dealt
long before with somebody dying which is
that uh we need to address people
getting signed into contracts that are
coercive or uh in some way not properly
explained to them which again this
contract does attempt to do in Fairly
broad ways but again it's a summary it's
going to be a little bit broad so that
was another thing I saw a lot of people
freaking out about that I wanted to get
some clarification in there on again to
the best of my knowledge there's also an
interesting thing about synthetic
performers these being um ones that are
not based off an actress so they didn't
scan somebody they didn't motion capture
anybody's performance they're just
creating with AI tools usually a crowd
or something of that nature now the
contract does something interesting with
that which is that it doesn't strictly
forbid it but it basically requires any
given movie that wants to do that to
make a case before the Union as to why
they should be allowed to do that with
AI tools instead of making use of actual
actors and also there's a caveat that it
does not apply to non-human actors so it
won't apply if they need you know to
create a stampede with a mass of animals
or if it's a huge crowd of aliens in a
Star Wars movie that they can just go
ahead and do but if it is meant to be
people there is some language in there
to at the very least not just give free
reign to Studios to just fill out crowds
with nothing but AI derived um actors
you know that aren't even necessarily
based off anybody at least in theory
there's a whole side conversation to be
had about generative Ai and how
generative it is as opposed to actually
stealing people's work and likenesses
and recobing it together but that is a
much larger discussion that's probably
going to have to play out in court uh
over the next decade or so to figure out
how that's exactly going to work but
again I feel like most things are at
least attempting to be addressed in this
from my vantage point that of a
semi-educated
commentator most points that I've seen
be issues are addressed the question is
are they addressed as thoroughly as they
could be and as foolproof as they could
be and there are definitely some people
out there who have seen who believe that
that is not the case again though um I
caution against being overly granular
and picking apart the summary because it
is just a summary but there is certainly
still concerned that the way these
things are worded might still give some
leeway might still allow the studios to
do more than the spirit of the agreement
was intended to allow them to do and
those are legitimate concerns and we'll
see how play out in the next few years
it is worth noting this contract is only
for 3 years and while three years
technologically can mean a lot
ultimately especially with everything
having been pushed back months if not a
year if not two years on some schedules
three years is not that long where if
the studios start taking advantage of
the way these things are worded it's G
to come up again in contract
negotiations and not that far in the
future and no that's not me saying like
any problems we'll patch it later no no
I'm not Bethesda no if there were
problems ideally they shouldn't be there
in the first place and uh addressed
right now would be preferable but it's
not like they're locked into this
forever they have a fairly short amount
of time before the next contract comes
up and if the holes have started to show
with this agreement particularly in
regards to the AI they will have the
chance to address and plug them now
there is still some danger there because
remember how I said before that part of
why this is more complicated because AI
has already become standard to a certain
degree if some sneaky found a loophole
use of AI Andor rights to people's
likenesses and performances starts to
become standard before the next contract
comes up that could be a problem but
again that is kind of going down the
what if path like is that possible
yeah it's hard to know though are these
100% fo
foolproof probably not but how much the
studios are actually going to be able to
get away with in a way that won't
ultimately just bite them in the ass uh
when we get around to the next
negotiating phase and especially
considering that Congress has considered
looking at um putting forth legislation
to restrict the use of generative AI in
Creative Fields I don't necessarily
expect that that will happen cuz
Congress is a dysfunctional mess but
it's been
proposed and by and large as with the
writers the vast majority of people are
on the actor side the studios don't have
a lot of backing on this and while there
was no call for a consumer boycott this
strike I think that it's pretty clear
just from the hit that was taken from
actors not going out and promoting this
stuff and like there's a number of
reasons that some high profile flots
have happened but that certainly hasn't
helped while the strike has been going
on if the actors felt they were getting
screwed so badly they actually called
for a consumer
boycott I don't think the studios can
afford to dance with that um now I've
said in the past that boycotts don't
work but I've said that in the sense of
like consumer more organized like you
know boycotts of a of a video game of
this show of this studio generally no
they don't and that's not to say you
shouldn't Stand by Your principles and
not put money towards something by all
means but um if the actual performers
the people who you know audiences like
said that we are getting screwed over
please help us not be screwed over would
it be most audiences no probably not
would it be enough to be a immediate
noticeable problem yeah yeah it would so
I'm not a dumer on this I look at this
and I and to my eyes my untrained my not
a contract lawyer eyes this seems like
it's definitely making a solid attempt
to address everything is there stuff
that I can't think of that might have
holes yeah no absolutely that is
distinctly
possible but I think a lot of people who
are doing the harshest possible read are
assuming a
of cavalier malice on the parts of the
studios that I think is a little
unreasonable now this is not me giving
benefit of the doubt to Studios they're
corporations screw them but they do
still have people to answer to be it
shareholders be it board members be it
whatever else and this strike did not do
well for the studios so they're probably
not going to have a lot of backing even
internally for another move to tick off
the unions I think the way that these
strikes have gone is a way that is going
to overall strengthen them and make the
studios a bit more cautious about
brazenly being the kinds of jackasses
that uh
negotiations prior to them finally
settling on this indicated they really
wanted to be I don't doubt that Studios
want to be able to pay an actor for
their likeness once record some voice
lines from never pay them again and use
their image as AI forever I don't doubt
that they want to do
that but I do doubt that they think they
could get away with that right now at
least anytime soon and that's a start is
that everything no keep a Vigilant eye
on corporations always and forever but
I'm still feeling largely positive about
this while acknowledging that maybe
there's some holes and maybe maybe in a
year's time I'll be eating my words
because there was a massive hole that I
didn't see but from where I sit this
definitely the non-ai stuff I think is
pretty much all good and the AI related
stuff the spirit of it I'm 100% behind
and I don't know enough about uh
contract law to say whether the uh
specifics will net the intended result
but I'm hopeful and I'm certainly glad
to see um you know the studios cave
there's a catharsis to a few weeks ago
them them going to the actors offering
their best and final offer the actor's
walking away and then the studio is
coming back a week later with a
different offer than their best and
final offer I'm going to take my uh my
catharsis in that and be happy with it
cuz you know could use a
win in some things this has been a heck
of a year and and uh I'll take a win
where I can get it is it a total win
nah but I think it's a net
positive so that's my overview for the
saaa ending of the strike the uh
proposed contract that needs to be
ratified My overall thoughts on it as I
said some people are not positive on it
at all
I'm that feels overly pessimistic to me
but again that's just where I'm at what
do you think what are your thoughts on
any of this
uh even if you disagree with me and you
think I'm a fool you can disagree with
me just you know let's not do name
calling and accusing anybody of being a
shill or being paid or anything else the
only people paying me are my patreons
support me uh over there to keep this
whole thing up and running but other
than that I want to hear your thoughts
drop them down in the comments let's
talk about it there are other things
that I do around the net you can check
out links in the description but what I
really want you to
remember is that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are
loved you're the council and I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned time to thank some patrons and
this time I'm going to say their names
as if I'm greeting them welcoming them
to a party Robin Moore zumin Lula godess
Salida Tac the thing that goes don't in
the anime Ruth goeser the goeran Oliver
be
solitary pictures rri Bogden Melinda
Walters Jen Auntie K 808 Becky Sparks
forab likes the poodle Robin Powell TLO
Tracy scrapit angry Casper Dave Hall
Rosalyn Bennett have fun tonight and
thank you for your support I don't know
why I decided to do that this time but I
don't know I'm having
fun
[Music]
down